now I have a better understanding of
what happened then looking back I can go
okay I took way too long to get this
point but finally I achieved that level
up as far as balance my next phase was
realizing what I had messed up where
where I had screwed up Luke was the
screw-up
the screw-up was still learning what the
screw up as the screw up was that
deflecting right what was deflecting but
why was i deflecting and-and-and in the
deflecting I had built up this ego of of
who I was and that's also it was fear
the focus deflecting out of fear okay so
I was deflecting out of fear because I
played Superman I jumped I he this huge
to the front of the line I'd done
auditions and I'd been on stuff before
but I really jumped to the front of the
line when I did that movie yeah and then
I wasn't given what I thought I was or
had earned I wasn't getting offers hey
isn't that kind of an EFT way of looking
at things cuz I know yeah because we
feel like well we deserve this yeah very
hard I deserve and it's like it's hard
to it is ego and it's hard to imagine
like it's a that takes time to change
your way of thinking doesn't a very long
time I I was told by my you know
representatives and everyone they
thought it was gonna be a big deal right
that's what happens you do a big movie
and then you do other well then they
tell I read that they actually your
agent took you on because like you look
sort of like resemble Christopher Reeve
so I'm gonna having my back pocket cuz
he's destined to play that role is that
sort of why he became your agent well
originally that was what he said to me
then but that I no longer what that
agent dropped me after I got after I
fired a soap opera I was on back in 2001
anyway so they missed out on that day
sure did but that didn't happen when
well the only offers I was getting more
horror movies which I didn't which I
love the way I look around you Fright
Night I got Dracula over here Rudy isn't
a horror movie but you know yes it's a
wonderful movie didn't all these other
offers and things for projects that I
didn't that weren't in line with what I
wanted to write not a lot but they but
what offers work
worth four things that I just had no
interest in and I didn't see them moving
my career forward and in the path that I
wanted I had to audition for things and
there were things that came very close
that there that I was working with on
the studio that just didn't they didn't
pull out if they were in production and
it didn't happen couple other things
that just didn't happen but by and large
I was not a qualified auditioner it was
it's the worst thing in the world it's
advice better now I feel like I'm better
now I have more confidence in myself and
many other things that kind of help make
that better right but I was I was not a
good audition er except for things that
I was really right for right which is
why you get the things you're really
right for anyway so I I didn't do the
work I I didn't read scripts well enough
I didn't I I was my foot was halfway out
the door every time I was going in so
all right then I was probably creating a
bad reputation for myself with casting
offices and and producers and things and
so but I was in denial of all this
fervor for for quite a while and I had
great opportunities thankfully that came
along you know with Zack & Miri and Ken
Smith you know and Scott Pilgrim about
that yeah loves that I got to see that
that's really a lot of my friends have
seen and they love that so I got to see
that yes that's a class worthwhile movie
all right I'm gonna and then with Chuck
and so I had things you know thankfully
kept me afloat and learning along the
way but it wasn't until I really till I
really understood that I needed to start
again that I needed to relearn things
and relearn how to not and relearn but I
had to go back I had to go back and and
actually learn how to audition for
myself and re-engage myself and really
become part of the process and fully
it's looking back I can call it
surrender I can say that I had to
surrender to the process and surrender
to the fact that I had to audition and
became disciplined it sounds like yes I
started to work hard and so that started
you know the first thing that started
was happened as I after I took on that
mentality was I got the pilot the the
sitcom that I did
called partners in 2012 and that was a
wonderful experience and would love to
be still doing it to this day but we did
13 episodes and that was the end of that
then shortly after that was some
opportunity for for for arrow and I you
know they they I brought in a had a
meeting with the producers but then I
had to go back and I read with a
wonderful Emily
Ricketts and and did a chemistry test
with her and so I had to prove myself
that's the thing you always you have to
prove yourself and I'm like listening
you it's funny because sometimes I think
I'm gonna have nothing in common with
people and then you start talking for
everything we all have things that are
in common like there is an ego ego is
such a big part of everyone's life that
they probably ruin a lot of
opportunities and I remember I had
opportunities but it was egos lack of
discipline I don't want to go learn this
I I just sort of embarrassing if I look
back I'm like you [ __ ] pompous little
[ __ ] and for you to go you know you have
an audition with uh you know Tom Hanks
or something I mean I've worked on that
one but uh you know
Good Will Hunting and Saving Private
Ryan and I remember those like that
night before party and I was a kid I was
like 26 and I was like I'm gonna go I
didn't get a [ __ ] like the guy I wasn't
mature and by the way maturity isn't
something that is in my vocabulary
but I'm very responsible and you know it
takes time you say it takes time to sort
of like look back and go hey this is
this is where I was [ __ ] out this is
this is why and you said you learn you
relearn things